ああああああ
すごく安のハードルを上げ上げの中であるので緊張しているんですけれども
どうぞよろしくお願いします
今日はめんどくさいから始めるデザインについてお話しさせていただきたいと思います
いきなりなんですけれども皆さん大学生の方はどのぐらいいらっしゃいますか
多いですねじゃあこの中で理系ですという方は
やっぱり系の方が多いです
そんなに系の方にもデザインというものをしてもらいたいなと思って今日はお話しさせ
ていただきます
まずデザインと聞くとなんとなくカッコイイとか
自分には関係ないそういうふうに思っている方が多いかもしれません
0しましたコレットすればいいですか
はいででは面倒くさいと聞くと何を思い浮かべますか
これまで面倒くさいのと何かしら感じたことがある方
せません点を挙げていただいてもいいですか
じゃあ何が面倒くさいと思いましたか
はい何でも大丈夫
さぁ今日もゆっくり従っ
ええええええ
そんな面倒くさい時にそれがどうすれば面倒くさくないんだろうって考えたことはあり
ますか
そんなときにこそ行ってみて欲しいデザインをデザインについてお話ししたいと思い
ます
まずデザインと一体何なのでしょうか
では具体的に何かを形作ることとしてデザインという言葉を使われていました
のデザインなったりこのような服のデザインだったり
あとは建物をを5のデザインやっぱりそのように見た目をデザインするという意味で
言葉が使われてきました
しかし近年では何かしらの問題に対して
階級するための課題を見究問題を解決へと導く方法という意味で
デザインという言葉は疲れてきています
人と人の関係をデザインする仕組みをデザインする
このように具体的な形がないものに対してもデザインという言葉が使われているの
こういう解決問題を解決へと導く方法という意味で使われるようになってきたからです
ここで少し面倒くさいことテロとデザインが詰まっ
がってきたものなのでしょうか
つまり面倒くさいことを解決する
このプロセスこそが不在のせい
面倒くさいと感じた時に何もしないのが普通の人
問題を極めて解決するのがデザイナーというふうに定義してみると先ほどては負けて
いただいたように皆さん
デザイナーになれる可能性があるのです
もちろん誰しもがデザイナー群れっていうのがありません
しかし
めんどくさいを解剖するということを通してみなさんデザインを少しわかってもらおう
かなと思っています
手元にカモられている袋の中にシートが入っているのでぜひいらしてみてください
これは彼の本音が書いてあります
このシートの使い方なんですけれどもまず一番右の頭の部分
何かめんどくさいことを書き込んでみてください何でも構いません
頭に思い浮かんだものをぜひ書いてみてください
だけました感じん
では次にそれを
なぜだけいろんな角度から見つめなおしてみます
例えば私の場合食器洗いがめんどくさいっていうのがあるのでそれに対して
頻度という視点から
1やっているか
それをする時にどんな木も付き合っていいのか
そのことに対してどんな先入観を持っているのか
だいたいテーマはどのくらいかかるのかなどなるべく多くの視点からその問題
問題ダウめんどくさいと思ったことについて書き込んでみてください
あくまでもここに書き込んだりもヒントでしかないのでそれ以外にもこういうのが
めんどくさいなぁとかあったらどんどん
この真ん中の骨から線を伸ばしてか突っ込んで行ってみてください
だいたいダイコームから書き込めたよという方は混乱するをさあに分解してみます
例えば私の場合いってもというので15分くらいかかりそうというところ
さらに細く開けてみるとラッパーとに乾いてから片付けるって言うことに時間が割かれ
ているんじゃないかなと思いました
皆さんも書き込んでいただいた太鼓門から3以降枝を分岐させて細かく細かく分けて
行ってみてください
匹終わったよという方
てっ
最後にこれを全体シート全体をえっと
なるべく高俯瞰するようなイメージで見てみてください
そこに何かきっとその面倒くさいことをどうすれば面倒くさくないかと考えるヒントが
書いてあるはずです
例えば私の場合では洗い物が15分くらいか偽装は徒パートに乾いてから片付けるのに
手間がかかるということについて考えてみました
実際に洗い物15分もかかっているのかこれを測ってみると
実際は5分くらいで終わりました
さらに洗ったあとにそのお皿を片付けるのが面倒くさいので洗い物をする時は洗い物を
するだけにして次にお皿を使うときに使わなかったお皿を片付けるというように
洗い物とかた月を別々にすることで
これまでよりも辛いもの自体が面倒くさくなくなりました
このように面倒くさいプー普段はただ面倒くさいということを考えることすらめんど
くさいと思ってしまうかもしれませんが
実際その面倒くさいということをどうすれば面倒くさくないかなと考えるのは非常に
論理的なもん
作業です
そして今この皆さんに考えていただいたプロセスこそがんデザインと思っています
私はよく東工大出身のにデザイナーなんだと驚かれるのですか
際には意見も文系の芸術系も関係ないと考えています
特に皆さん理系の方が多いということでしたがそんな理系の皆さんにこそデザインをし
ていってほしいです
なぜなら数学の問題を解くということは非常にデザインすることと似ているからです
その数学の問題は極めて
どうすればその問題が解けるのかなるべく細かく問題を分割して一体何が自分に地下れ
ているのかというのを考えてみると
実際自分にも解くことができたという経験が少なからずあるのではないでしょうか
なのでそんな数学の問題を解いてきた皆さんにこそ
剤というのはできるはずですしどんどんしていってほしいのです
是非今後生活をしていて何かめんどくさいなぁと思ったらそれをきっかけにデザイン
するということを意識してみてください
どうすれば面倒くさくなくなるのかなぜ自分面倒くさいと思っているのか少し考えて
みるだけでその解決策が見えてくるはずです
そして今非常に小さな面倒くさいというのをきっかけにお話ししましたがデザインと
いうのがパチを吸っ2つにすることだけではなくなっているからこそ社会のすべての
領域に使ってくるこのか乗ってきています
私はデザインというものには今井お話ししたように問題を解決する以上のことができる
と信じています
人を惹き付けて人を動かしの中をハッピーにしていけるようなエネルギーを水瀬力が
あると私は信じています
だからこそ皆さんも一緒に何かをデザインして問題を解決するだけではなくそこに少し
プラスの価値を追加して
世の中をより良くしていけるようなデザインをして行ってみてください
ご静聴ありがとうございました